Hey guys, everything CNC here. Today I
wanted to do a little topic on uh
grooving. I got some people requesting
for grooving and threading. So, I'm
going to try and do uh the four major
grooving tool pass as quick as I can. Um
I already showed you how to set up a um
page, a blank page, and then fill out a
couple of informations as far as uh edge
facing and bar out. So, I'm not going to
do those again. I'll just go over it
briefly. Um, I apologize for the quality
and uh the huge delay in uh um shooting
any more videos, but until I get my new
camera should be here in a couple of
weeks, uh I'm going to go ahead and uh
do this uh for you. Okay, so we have uh
just a basic cylinder 4 in uh uh in
length and 2 in in diameter. We're going
to start off with a raw stock of 2 and
1/2 in that we're going to turn down.
These are the four uh grooving types.
I'm going to go ahead and go over them
and I'm just going to make up a fake uh
thread here. I'll say uh uh what is they
here? 1 and 1/2 uh 10 or 1 and 12,
whatever you guys want to do. Um we'll
go ahead and go over it just to show you
the basic threading tool path. Uh and
then another video we'll go ahead and do
some ID turning boring and stuff like
that. But I'm going to see how I'm going
to lay out this uh for future videos. So
for now, we have our uh uh aluminum
here. Just put down whatever you want.
uh 2 and 1/2 in diameter raw stock.
Okay, so that's going to be the starting
point for all our X moves. Don't worry
about the inside. We don't have a hole
in there already on the fixture. Damn,
my fingers are greasy. Uh hopefully it
doesn't smudge it up too much. Uh our
length is 4 in. But remember, you got to
add extra material for your facing
operation to clean up the raw stock on
the face. And then you got to add if
you're going to part off the thickness
of the tool and how much material you're
leaving extra. Otherwise, it'll give you
an error and say, "Hey, uh, you want to
machine more than what material he gave
me." Uh, we're going to finish uh, with
aluminum, I always finish 5,000 on the
X, and I finish 5,000 on the Z, which is
the face of the material. And I always
remove typically 25,000 from the face of
the material if it's a bar stock. So, we
have our edge face under uh, unit number
one. Okay. We're going to start with a
roughing surface feed of,200, and we're
going to finish with a surface feed of
1,200. Uh this is just for an example,
okay? You could definitely take heavier
cuts, but you know, for me, I'll do
10,000 in this video uh of depth step
over and uh I mean, sorry, 10,000 step
down for a facing and 25,000 step over
uh for depth of cut. Our roughing tool
is one and finishing tools one. Our
starting point for X is going to be at
the diameter of our stock or more. Okay?
You never want to start below the stock,
otherwise you'll crash the tool on X.
Uh, we're going to go from a positive
X2.5 to an X of0, which is center of the
part. And we're going to start 25,000
away from the material and finish at Z0,
uh, which is the face of the part. And
we're going to leave a finishing of
30,000,
uh, per step over or per revolution.
We're going to bar out 2 and 1/2 uh, in
starting point on X. And we're going to
start at Z0 because we already finished
our face to Z0. So we no longer have to
leave a extension of stock material. And
we're going to do 1200 1200 10,000 uh
step over per revolution at a depth cut
of 25,000.
So every time the part rotates, we're
going to step over 10,000 digging into
the material 25,000 deep. Okay, that's
how that goes. Uh one and one are going
to be my tool numbers again. And it's
going to be a line with a chamfer of
5000. So just on the very front end,
we're just going to kill that corner. I
use it as deburring as probably 90% of
all other machine shops do. They throw
like a 5,000 around it. You'll find
fine. Uh and we're going to finish it to
a diameter of two and a length of 4 in.
Usually you're going to want to leave uh
material more for when you flip it
around and you face it. Uh you'll have,
you know, 10,000 extra material there.
uh and you know to pass the cutter
radius uh past the point of where you
want it to machine finish to and 3000
stepover. So let's just get right into
the grooving. Okay, for the first groove
we're going to go ahead and do this guy.
You're going to select the number that
looks like that. Okay, we're grooving to
a total diameter of 1.75.
Okay, and that's from the inside inside
there. So if you were to take calipers
and you were to measure it, that's the
number you would get. That's how you
program these guys. Now, these ones get
programmed from Z0 onto this face or
when you look at it, it's going to be up
here. Okay. So, from Z0 to the first
part of the face. And how you can double
check that is going into uh the mode,
we're going to say we're going to
groove. It's going to be an outside
groove and it is number two. Okay. But
if you ever get stuck, and sometimes I
forget as well, click over one and click
help. And that will display all the
information you need. I mean everything
you need. It tells you your start point,
your finish point. It gives you an
example of pitch. It tells you what
number and what cor uh what correlates
to what number and what shape. And it
tells you, okay, if I program this guy,
you are going to calculate from Z0,
which is this guy here, back out here.
And then when you tell it its width,
it's going to calculate this direction.
Okay? So start, finish, and this
direction. If you say a number one,
you're going to calculate it from Z0.
And this is going to be your starting
point. Okay? From Z0 to here. And when
you type in your width, it's going to
work back in this direction. Okay? So
that that's how that works. But right
now, we are going to go ahead and do
this guy right here. And uh it from Z0
to the front starting point is going to
be 1.25. Okay.
So we're going to go ahead and click
number one. Oh, I'm sorry. This will
mirror that side onto here. Uh we are
going to use number two. Okay.
And it's going to be number of grooves.
It's just going to be one. If you were
to put more than one, you could tell it,
hey, from here to there, I want to do
like five grooves. And it'll do the
pitch just like a thread. Okay. Uh
grooving pitch, just hit enter. Don't
need to worry about it. The width of the
groove is 250. 250.
Okay. The finish we'll just say 0003
and that's how much stock it's going to
leave to take off. Uh surface feed for
that we'll say 500 and 500 finishing.
And then uh feed rate per rough cut for
revolution we'll say 0003 as well. Uh
you can do whatever you want. Find out
what works best. Material uh reacts
widely different from uh material to
material. So uh you'll just have to look
that up in a machinist handbook or
figure it out. uh rough max depth to cut
is going to be uh 0.025. We'll just go,
you could say way more than that, but
like I said, for example purposes, this
is what we're going to do. And our
roughing tool number, we'll say three
cuz that's what it is on the machine
here. And uh I'm sorry, two is what it
is. And two, I have to say the actual
tool in order to see the back plot
because it calculates all the
information from the tool. So, if you do
not have the tool set up or you
incorrectly select the tool number and
you don't have it configured in the
computer for your tool offsets and
stuff, it won't show you the correct
tool path or it will give you an error
and just won't show you anything at all.
So, you got to make sure when you select
the tool, it already has to be defined
in the computer. You don't need to
actually have the tool in the machine
and setup, but you need to have it
defined. Um, and that goes to this page
back here, tool data, and we select
number two. So you say groove out. I
have a 93,000 thickness cutter and each
side of the cutter is going to be 4,000
in radius. Okay, so that that's what I
mean by that. To go back, go program and
then hit program one more time in order
to edit. And let me scroll back down.
Okay, our uh radius, we don't need to
worry about that right now. Our starting
point on X is going to be the 2 in that
we turned it down to up here. Started at
2 and 1/2 to two. Okay. Our starting
point on Z is going to be uh let's see
here it's 1.25 from the face to back
here because if you remember when we
clicked help it said that we start from
that direction. U and I'll go back and
show you that real quick. Click help.
Oh, whoops. Wrong section here. Program.
So when you go over and you select you
see these you just click over and help
for that information. It says number two
starting point is here. Start point
finish point. So, wherever I start,
wherever I finish, and then I hit the
menu. Oh, let me close that. Okay. And
now we'll go ahead and uh go back to the
program here.
So, 1.250.
Okay. Final point on X is going to be
1.75. 1.75.
That is the diameter of the finished
groove. size this guy from the inside
diameter of where you would measure the
calipers or hopefully uh blade mic, you
know, to be a little bit more precise.
Um, and then the final point on Z um to
get an image of the angle. So, you start
up top and then wherever you finish, if
you finish on the Z point, same as here,
it'll just be a straight box. If you
wanted to finish over a little bit,
we'll say we started at 1.25, 25. Let's
say 1.35.
Okay.
So, now we're going to start and finish
at a little bit of an angle. Don't worry
about the corner radius and the angle.
You could say an angle, you know, and
it'll calculate automatically for you.
But feed rate per rev, we'll say 03.
Okay. And there you go. So, let's check
it out. Program tool path. Part shape.
Check. Continue.
[Music]
Oh, whoops. It's chucking me. There we
go. Roughing.
Finishing. And now it's stepping in and
doing an angle and finishing. Okay,
let's go ahead and uh tool path erase.
Check. Continue. Once it gets close,
I'll go ahead and uh Oh, okay. Let me
zoom in. Scale change.
And then I'm going to say 0.5. Okay.
Part shape.
Check. Continue once it gets close here.
Okay. Okay. So, it's going down.
Then it's stepping over
and cutting more relief. Then it's going
to step over, cut more relief. Okay. And
now it's going to come in and finish.
Okay. Here it goes.
There you go. So, that is your start
point.
That is your finish point. Remember, we
started at the distance from zero to
here. And then for this finish point, we
started at a further distance from zero
to there. We defined the x the diameter
from this top to the other top or the
bottom and then uh we gave it a step uh
a width when you describe the width from
here to here and that was 250. So that's
how that group goes. Now
uh program
let's go ahead and uh go to the next
one. program
groove out
and we're going to say number zero or
zero
number of grooves we're just going to
say one grooving pitch we only have one
we don't need to worry about pitch the
width of this groove is 275
okay finishing 500 okay and our
finishing feed rate per rev 03
Our max depth of cut, we'll say 0.025.
And our tool once again is going to be
number two. Okay, we'll put a radius at
the top of each corner on here. Uh,
actually we'll just put a chamfer 0005.
Okay, our starting point is going to be
2 in again. And our Zpoint now when we
do this one, we calculate it from the
back side. So we take from the front all
the way to the back side. If you look in
the help menu, that's what it says. Um,
don't ask me why. It's just it's how
they made this program. So, our Zpoint
is going to be 225.
Our final X point is going to be the
minimum diameter that the groove goes
down to, which is 1.5. Okay. And our Z
point is going to be the exact same
thing because it's a straight part. So,
we're going to say 2.125.
Okay. So, our start point and our end
point is a vertical line. So we just say
it's the same Z angle. Don't worry about
taper. There's no taper. Our feed rate
per rev 0003. And now let's check it
out. Program tool path part shape.
Check. Continue.
Now you should be able to see it.
Okay, it's going down. It's going to go
down again. Wonder if I can just hold
it. No. Okay. Check. Continue. So, it's
going to keep going, roughing it out,
and then it's going to uh just leave it
there. Okay? There's no finishing
operation on this one. Okay? You're
going to have to do uh a different type
of tool path, which could be this one if
you were to do straight, or you could go
to um another program that would do this
guy. Just don't put any taper on it.
It'll rough it and it'll finish it. So,
we'll go ahead and do the next one.
program groove. Oh, let's get this in
focus. I haven't really been paying
attention to that. I hope it's been in
focus.
Okay, so we'll do bar groove out. And
the next one we're going to do is a
number three. Okay, number of grooves,
we just have one. Pitch, don't worry
about it. Width of groove is going to be
0506506.
Finish 0.33. And we're going to do a 500
surface feed. 500 surface feed for
finish. Now, this one has a finish. So,
we're going to do uh 0.003 per rev.
Depth 0025 just for an example. And
we're going to have tool number two
again. Okay. For our chamfer on one
side, it's only going to chamfer. And
that's the far side. Um we'll go ahead
and put 005.
Starting point in X is going to be 2 in.
Again, starting point in Z. This is
measuring from the back side, the side
closest to the spindle again. So, this
is going to be 2.854. 2.854.
Oh, wow. Uh 2.854.
And the X point on this is going to be
1.652. 1.652.
Z is going to be the same exact thing.
Uh oh, actually, we'll make it go closer
to the front. So, we'll say it's uh two
point uh uh let's say 750. Okay.
And feed rate 03.
And let's go ahead and check it out now.
Program tool path part shape. Check.
Continue. So, there's the taper. We
started at this Z and we moved it closer
to the origin. So, that's why it has the
taper.
[Music]
It's running. Now, it's roughing. And
now it's going to come back and finish
the bottom. The one thing to note is
that when you do these angled uh these
two angled ones, it does not finish this
backside wall. Okay? Those don't get
finished. It just goes finishes here,
goes to there, and rapids out. So, if
you didn't have an operation that was
needed uh for roughing, uh I'm sorry, if
you didn't have an if you had an
operation that wasn't needed to have a
nice finish on the back, it's great.
It's real quick. But if you need to have
a nice finish on the back, you're going
to need need to do something uh like
this and then throw this guy in there or
throw this guy in there to finish up the
backside face. So, let's go ahead and
move on to the last uh grooving tool
path that I'm going to show you. And
that is going to go back program and hit
program one more time. Remember to edit
it. And we're going to say it's another
groove. And then out. And what was the
last one? Is going to be this guy. Now,
whatever you do from one side, it's
going to replicate to the other. You're
going to say it's one groove. Pitch is
nothing. Don't worry about it. And the
width of this one is 630. Okay? That's
from the top end to the top end, not the
bottoms. Okay? And our finish is going
to be 03. Feed rate 500 rough feed rate
500 surface finish. uh I mean uh for
finishing 003 per rev depth 0025 for an
example two for roughing tool two for
finishing tool we're going to say 05
chamfer our starting point is 2.0 know
finishing point is going to be uh 2.940
2.940
okay
so these ones get finished from Z0 to
the front face not the back ones okay so
Z0 to the front face you can click the
help menu once again to get to the help
menu you highlight the number that you
when you see these click over one button
hit help and it tells you okay so for
this tool starting point finishing point
and width now I'm not going to do a
taper on this one. Actually, I will.
Okay, I'll do a taper for you guys so
you can get the example. Uh, let's go
back to the program program and go down.
Zdepth is uh 2.940.
Okay,
now final X point we have 1.566.
Uh, final point on Z. If we did 2.940
here, we need to add more in order to
get a taper. But I'm going to do another
way of of programming it. I'm going to
say final point Z is a a question mark.
Okay. So, I'm going to have an angle and
I'm going to have it calculate for me.
So, I put, hey, I don't know the final Z
point, but I know the angle and it's
going to be 30°. Okay, taper angle 30°.
My finish feed rate is uh 03.
And then let's check it out. See what I
did. program tool path part shape
and uh okay so my angle was too steep
because I just made up an angle. Let's
go back program
and
we'll say that uh
we'll say that it's uh 15° and then I
got to replace this with the question
mark again and it's going to calculate
it itself. tool path part shape.
Oh,
did it again. There we go.
60°. There we go. Went the wrong way.
Question mark.
There we go. Okay, now we're going to
check continue. Okay, it's running it.
And go through that guy.
Now, with all the years I've been doing
this, I don't know how to skip right to
this stuff. If somebody knows how to,
please let me know. Okay, so now it's
roughing the center, and now it's
finishing half and goes back to the
other half and finishes half. So, let's
go ahead and zoom in. Scale change. And
this is one of my favorite ones to use,
by the way. Here we go. Let's say uh it
What are we at right now? It shows you
right up at the top here. 1.3. So, I'm
going to say 0.5. And then part shape.
I'm going check continue. Let it run
through everything and then once it gets
close, we'll go ahead and uh stop this.
So, it's doing the other ones right now.
Yeah, it's kind of a pain when you have
a big program though, too, to watch it.
Okay, so check step.
Okay, it's starting. It's starting in
the center. It looks a little offset,
but that is not calculating the width of
the tool. So the tip of the tool that
touches the sensor is always the little
arrow and our thickness of the tool is
going that way. So from here that way
it's 93,000. So we actually are cutting
dead center of the part. Okay. And then
it's going to step over. It's going to
do another cut and then another cut and
then it's going to jump back to the
center and start doing the other half.
And then it'll finish that and finish
the other half. And it's a really really
nice, very versatile uh type of uh
grooving to do. Um that one. And then
one of the angled uh ones on the corner,
which are these guys here. Let me
highlight it. Program.
Go back. Help. Uh this guy, and then one
of these. You'll find that you could use
that combination in almost every single
possible groove that you could do. Now,
this is exactly exactly the same on ID
grooves, okay? You just tell it to start
on the inside and then to what diameter?
Outer diameter. When you're doing the
outside, you say start on the outside
diameter and work your way into the
inner diameter. It's just basic common
sense. I mean, uh, but it does take a
little bit to figure out how to do it.
And once you get to doing it, uh, any
machinist who's an actual machinist
knows how to figure out and go from
there. So, here's a little jump start. I
hope this helped. And, uh, let me know
if I should do this in a different way
or if uh, you know, I completely suck at
this and, uh, just get somebody else to
do it. But, I hope, you know, that me
taking a couple minutes and showing you
guys how to do something is uh, good
enough. Um, let me know, comment, uh,
subscribe, do whatever you guys do. And,
uh, I'll see you guys later in another
video.